everyone has seen this by now right oh
my gosh dude this this was dope
yeah cougar a guy was going jogging
right this guy but here is my thing
why is this guy so friendly this [ __ ]
cougar why wouldn't you take a [ __ ]
rock
and hit him in this software he knows i
thought that too but i'm thinking like
what am i going to
when you squat i mean they're they're
really yeah
that's one thing to do like if you what
if you aggravate him too like he's just
kind of trying to scare you but then you
throw something at him then he just
comes at you no the the throwing would
scare him but like
it's just they're i don't like how
friendly it was like come on bro
ah you gotta act big you gotta like
my bad i thought you was talking about
an older one you haven't seen this
i apologize i didn't know you all
talking about animals it's six minutes
it's so long but then you can kind of
see like give me the keyboard
he comes at him for at first though he
was jogging across and saw like two baby
cougars
and then out of nowhere the mother comes
out like he's like oh [ __ ]
she was just protecting her that's why
that's probably why she ran back though
definitely but wait
i think i'm an animal enthusiast is that
the word but look how
friendly he is though yeah no
why he just didn't start running you
cannot run around
you can't you can't turn your back like
i don't think
oh [ __ ] you see that he started going
out wait let me see one right there oh
he starts going like this
he could have picked up a rock a long
time ago holy
[ __ ] brandon you act like you know what
you would have been been able so
brilliant
i would have pegged that
real talk when they get hit yeah they do
like you know
they don't like it yeah they retreat
yeah have you seen them like you ever
seen a lion like
even barely get kicked or anything yeah
they hate it they hate it so they take
off yeah
he's surrounded by rocks he takes that
[ __ ] rock and you know when ryan that
thing in the stupid nose
you gotta get out you gotta aim like
that i'm gonna scare the [ __ ] out of me
i'm gonna hit him but what have you
missed though
you could [ __ ] well he's not gonna
like it though he's like oh [ __ ] no
this guy was too this guy was such a he
stalked him for six minutes well he
didn't want to hurt it he was like a
friendly vegan bro he's like come on man
i'm a good person leave me alone
you show the picture of him the part
where he throws the rock at it oh he's
zipped
a rock did he yeah watch that's how it
goes away you're kidding
yes what he did
watch you'll see and then it just starts
taking off oh so he's picking it right
there picking up right here
way too close i couldn't see him throw
it though
he called him a [ __ ] boy yeah i'll talk
[ __ ]
right i got [ __ ] where that came from he
called that damn thing a [ __ ] face
get out your [ __ ] face your [ __ ] face
that just happened
i love it's not as confession i would
keep going i wouldn't
i know exactly keep where she come back
with her homies
but dude he was so smart not turning his
back he was so smart about that
actually because they don't like to
fight common sense i feel like who the
[ __ ] would turn their back on
when you panic well i didn't know i mean
i i got chased in the hood now yeah
can you imagine the [ __ ] rainbow that
pops out the more you know the more you
if you're walking backwards you can't
see anything and you trip
it's over well not it's over you don't
fall when i work we don't really fall i
just see that excuse me rocks and stuff
i just can't believe you didn't pick up
like as soon as you threw the rock that
thing took off
yeah why would you wait six minutes
though [ __ ] i honestly didn't know if
that would work so
at that moment i didn't know a rock
would work because i thought maybe i'm
aggravating it no [ __ ] that but now
i'm gonna look into it [ __ ] that thing
so you all you gotta walk back
i don't believe them right now i'm gonna
figure it out later
well you know how they say get loud and
stuff those boys in uh washington
run that bike on a bike right now uh
mountain lion was stalking them
and so they decided to stop and get big
and bring up their bikes
like oh cool you guys are gonna stop
very cool attacked both of them
was eating his buddy and his buddy goes
oh [ __ ] dude i'll go get help
takes off the mountain lion goes where
the [ __ ] do you go leaves his friend
tackles that guy eats him alive and then
his friend got away
and then they went to find him and they
found the guy up in the tree and like
oh yeah because that's where they take
their that's real oh yeah kill the guy
that's a
can you imagine having someone believe
you 80 a year ago
a year ago yeah not that long ago
remember we had it was it out here
washington washington damn they're
saying this mountain lion was like
starving though that's when you get in
trouble if it's like starving like i
don't know so what do you do so
you throw the rock you gotta do fight
what you don't do is run like his [ __ ]
ass friend was like oh dude good luck
and took off running mountain lion's
like oh cool man i'm gonna get you
and yeah yeah you wouldn't run in those
that's food
that's the thing that's so wild about it
they're just trying to eat yeah that's
how they have to eat and protect their
young
protectors people think they're ruthless
like no they're not ruthless just
[ __ ]
hungry hungry pretty ruthless
they're going to eat you [ __ ] they're
going to eat you dude yeah because
they're hungry
so what would you do in the situation of
[ __ ] what would you do
if they're not hungry they won't [ __ ]
with you i don't know dude if you
they're the cubs or you stumble upon
them
can google that what if they if they
ain't hungry they ain't going to eat you
just put that in google
i think
[Laughter]
well that one said he really wrote it
does that help out what does it say it
doesn't say anything
it says it says uh research suggests
that when they are hungry the cats throw
caution in the wind
so yeah if they're hungry they're gonna
[ __ ] try and eat you mm-hmm how about
that
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this is from a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son